Now let's consider
the computational problem at hand.
Given a system of three planes.
Can we determine their
unique intersection point?
As we can see doing just a few steps.
The algebra is going to be a nightmare
if we try to symbolically solve for
the solution.
Also, it's not clear how generalized any
formulas we end up with to systems and
higher dimensions, which we
eventually like to be able to solve.
Instead, is there some sort of
algorithm we can follow that will
always find the solution
to a linear system?
In fact, there is.
The algorithm we will follow is based
on three operations that we'll apply to
the equations in the system.
However, before we start trying
to manipulate equations.
Let's think about what sort of
manipulations would be valid.
Primarily we don't want to do anything
that would change the geometry of
the planes represented by the equations,
and therefore change the solutions.
Also, we should be able to reverse
the operations we perform.
In order to obtain the original
pair of equations.
First of all,
it's certainly legal at any time to swap
the order of two
equations in the system.
Since intersections of planes don't
depend on the order in which we
list them.
This is perfectly fine.
We don't change our solution set at all.
Also, we can easily undo this operation
just by swapping the two equations
back to their original order.
What's another type of
operation we could do.
Well, if we have an equation and
we multiply both sides of
the equation by the same number.
Then the equation will stay true.
However if we were to
multiply through by zero.
Then the operation would
not be reversible.
We would not be able to divide through
by zero to obtain the original equation.
So we need to add a caveat.
We can multiply an equation
by any non-zero number.
Now, does this operation
preserve the solution?
Yes.
Multiplying through by a non-zero scalar
just multiplies the normal vector.
Whose coordinates are these
coefficients, by a scalar.
So we'll be pointing
in the same direction.
Moreover, you can algebraically
verify that any point you select
on the original plane satisfies
the new equation and vice versa.
So the two planes consist
of the same sets of points.
I.e., they're the same.
Also since we specify that alpha
must be a non-zero number.
The operation is reversible simply by
multiplying through by one over alpha.
Third, if we have two equations.
We can add one equation to the other.
Does this operation
preserve the solution set?
Well, suppose we had a point x,
y, z that was in
the intersection of two planes.
In other words the point x, y,
z satisfies both of these equations.
Now suppose we added the first
equation to the second equation.
This equation we know to be true,
because it was assumed true
in the previous system.
In the new second equation,
this quantity is equal to k one,
because of the first equation.
And this quantity is equal to k two,
because of the second
equation from the old system.
Therefore, this new
system is true as well.
X, y,
z satisfies both of these equations.
Therefore x, y, z is in the first
plane and in the new second plane.
Which means that the point x,y,z is in
the new intersection of the two planes.
Since this is true for any point,
x, y, z in the old intersection.
It means that all of the points in
the old intersection are contained in
the new intersection.
Also, because we can easily
reverse this operation
by subtracting the first equation
from the second in the new system.
This means that the new intersection
does not contain any points that weren't
in the old intersection.
So the intersections are the same.
So the solution is preserved.
Now suppose I modified the operation.
So that instead of adding just one
times the first equation to the second,
I add an arbitrary amount.
Alpha, times the first equation
to the second equation.
Notice that the same logic I applied
earlier also holds in this case.
So instead of just adding some
equation to another equation.
I can add a multiple of
one equation to another.
As I stated earlier, it's easy to
reverse this operation as well.
We just need to add negative alpha
times the first equation to the second
equation, to get back
to the original system.